hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
we're uh back to school again uh this
time and not a very dense topic but
uh quite non-intuitive if you read my uh
speaker reviews you see there's always a
statement at the beginning this is all
the listening tests are performed in
mono
many people quickly
dismiss the results then saying what the
hell is this guy doing who
listens to speakers one at a time and
therefore everything he says must be
wrong he doesn't know what he's doing
uh i do know what i'm talking and it's
not my idea
it builds on decades of research in this
area that
demonstrates why mono listening is much
more
useful and powerful in determining the
fidelity of a speaker
than stereo or multi-channel so i
thought i
covered the literature in this area
is the kind of information where uh most
audiophiles
don't seem to be aware of at all the
information is is not readily available
to them
and so everybody just goes by they light
intuition that uh it's all about
you know two speakers and imaging and
all these aspects so
let's go over that and uh let me start
with
uh where the research started uh
almost uh 40 years ago 1983 uh 38 years
ago
the research was performed by dr floyd
tulle
when he was part of the doing research
at national
research council in canada the canadian
government had built this
research institute to help the local
industry in canada
you know advance their knowledge and
competitiveness in the world
and one area they had was audio research
and
that's where companies like paradigm
anthem psp and others
started all canadian companies
so dr floyd tool went there and
did a lot of study of of you know
what speaker people prefer and why
but also one of the things he did was
that comparing
stereo versus mono listening clearly
doing stereo testing is a lot more time
consuming than doing mono testing
especially if you want to
do a blind test where you want to switch
speakers
switching two speakers is much more
difficult than switching just one
speaker so
uh he wanted to find out if if uh you
know what the difference was between the
two
um the paper is you know being old it's
kind of hard to read so i've just cut
and pasted a few sections of it
uh i encourage you if you want to read
it to uh
go and and uh download the paper from
audio engineering society or you can get
uh dr
floyd tools superb book sound
reproduction in rooms
and he goes over all these things in
there also
but anyway i'm going to quickly
summarize the key points of of the
present of the
paper they had the same uh four speakers
but organized in two separate uh rooms
one is that they were tested as as a
mono one at a time and they they were
not swapping them they were just
you know positioning very close together
so you had a slight angle error
but otherwise you know you could just
switch between a b and c and d
for stereo they actually put them on two
turntables and they would rotate the
turntables and get the two
uh speakers to align and then same
listening tests would be performed
the payback goes through great lengths
in the content they use these were
exceptionally well recorded uh concert
uh
recordings of different types with you
know multiple mics and
just stereo mics and you can read about
that in the paper so
this was kind of content that you know
was designed for this kind of testing
uh for both uh imaging testing and also
tonality
i'll jump right to the conclusion of the
paper because it's most important
but before i do they it's always useful
in these tests to have a control which
is uh
something that you know in advance to be
lousy they
have three speakers all three of them
were hardly you know well
rated in previous testing research they
had done but they also picked this other
speaker dd
that had this really bad subjective and
objective results and i'm showing you
the objective frequency response
measurement on the right
look at how it has this you know just
bases up here goes up and then it takes
a nosedive
and then the rest of the level it
doesn't even match the
woofer in there so clearly a screwed up
uh
you know two-way design of some sort and
off-axis is terrible so
they had this terrible speaker um when
they tested in mono
the three speakers sort of ranked one
two and three you can see they're
clustered together and confirmed that
what they already knew which is
these speakers rated well but with this
equality from four to eight or nine
in here vertically higher is the better
car is better
um and that look at speaker dd in manual
testing it
indeed you know finished a lot worse in
these things there's no question that
the speaker
that we knew in advance was bad was bad
but look at what happens when we switch
to stereo
uh first the three speakers maintain
their rankings one two and three is
essentially one two and three here
so whether we're testing a mono stereo
didn't make a difference their rankings
were both
for all three were very positive and
very high but also their
separation was also more or less the
same there's some degree of error in all
these tests they're
subjective after all so don't you know
micro focus into this thing but
essentially he
they're similar to each other but look
at what happened to speaker dd
all of a sudden when they were testing
stereo the same listeners
weren't so bothered by this crummy
speaker and they rated it
much closer to the uh
the three much better designed speakers
so
clearly the listeners were fooled by the
stereo effect
and what speaker that should have been
easy to rate as being terrible
became much harder so and the speakers
were good
you know stereo versus mono didn't make
a difference speaker that was bad
became more forgiven in in this uh
you know stereotesting
um a lot of people say well that's the
frequency response because
it's not everything how about stereo
imaging how can we measure stereo
imaging and i'm not going to get into
how we can measure there are a lot of
factors involved there
but uh this test actually went after
that and it's called spatial quality
spatial means two-dimensional
three-dimensional
beyond a point source it's a technical
term you'll see me use it a lot
instead of just saying stereo imaging
that which you know has
uh you know it's not as technically
correct
term and uh
here they tested again uh stereo versus
mono and this time they were asking them
in this column on the left is the sound
quality on the right they were asking
them
um what do you how do you rate the
spatial quality of
of this speaker and uh in mono look at
that we got one two and then the third
one is way the heck down here so
and very nice separation between these
three speakers
but look at when we look at the exact
same three speakers in stereo look at
this they're
clustered right together and listeners
could no longer determine the spatial
quality
of those speakers relevant relative to
each other
here everybody thinks if you put two
speakers in a room
you'll be able to hear the imaging a lot
better than if you do mono
now you might be saying what the hell is
he talking about what is mano's
imaging there's absolutely imaging
and indeed that was brought out in here
that this speaker the reason it was
rated so low
was that when listeners were listening
blind by the way all these are blind
listening with the curtain in front
they thought this speaker sounded like
an artificial point source
or like a clock radio or whatever it's
just
that was not pleasing to them whereas uh
these other speakers they have a softer
halo and
and imaging around the speaker it was
not a point
source which does not sound like reality
you know in real life if you were
listening to me
i'm not coming out of this one little
point in my mouth
there's a halo of sound that i'm
generating even though i'm in mono
listen to somebody speaking in a church
they don't sound like a little point
source there's an imaging there's a halo
around them
and and so speakers most definitely have
that why do they have that
because they sound they send sound to
the walls and that's a delayed sound and
it comes back
and generates a halo around the speaker
and actually
pulls the speaker's image uh
and that makes it sort of wider image so
it's not
in one spot so clearly
uh we were able to determine that a lot
better that a
speaker that wasn't very good at that
and provided this artificial point
source of sound
was rated low in mono but in stereo it
was
again a crapshoot both on fidelity which
i've already talked about on the left
and spatial quality all the speakers
were thought to be the same
whereas you look in here you can see the
wide variation one and two were good
speakers and the third one
was not and it's the same third one in
here that didn't do well in imaging
either
and you know everything's spaced out
apart
and we have better discrimination
of the fidelity of this speaker both in
tonal quality and
imaging on this now
you might say well that's an old study
well it was but the same set of people
that worked at nrc
spread out through the universe of of
audio
uh dr floyd toole and and uh
dr olive uh landed at harman um
some of the others landed at paradigm
and and psp and so forth
and uh while at harmon uh they uh
did a lot of uh studying of this also
because
again it's very time consuming to uh
do testing in in mono version stereo and
this paper was published um
years later uh 2008 and it wasn't
directly a test of this
in that the paper's overall thesis is
about the
new kind of room equalization that
harman was developing
and in the process they also tested it
to see how well it performed in
mono testing stereo testing and 5.1
multi-channel testing
i'll show you this room that i've been
at in harmon this is a purpose-built
room
uh complies with iac spec which is uh
what a standard listening room should be
there's a paper on this also an aes if
you want to read from sean
olive go through all the details but
essentially
excuse me there's a multi-channel system
over here you can see the speakers
spread out
in here and they show the speeds and
feeds of that
so what was the outcome there so they
were testing different algorithms
for uh room eq and comparing it to doing
nothing
so no eq means the speakers were playing
as is with
no no change no equalization then they
had
uh three different algorithms they were
applying one is
based on predicted in-room response and
in-situ and direct i won't get into one
what those are maybe one day i'll cover
room equalization later
uh in the future but for now just know
that
think of these as like three separate
speakers or three different sound
signatures because equalization changes
the
sound and uh listeners were listening to
all of these
in multi-channel or in stereo or mono
first let's start with multi-channel
which is this sort of this
white box with x towards it notice that
all four methods were the same
so doing nothing was the same as doing
something with this algorithm or this
algorithm or maybe a little bit better
with this algorithm
but essentially if you look at the error
bars
listeners said yeah i don't know what
this eq is doing or not doing
and when you change the algorithm it
also sounded the same
and so in multi-channel they couldn't
tell the difference between them
even though the algorithms technically
were very different then it switched to
stereo and that's this red line over
here
uh with a little triangle on it and look
at what happened all of a sudden
all the algorithms did better than doing
no eq which is this this
this line over here so all of a sudden
doing nothing is worse than doing
something
uh so it's a gap develop but look at
what happens when you go to do a mono
test and so you're only testing one
speaker all of a sudden
wow the listeners were like yeah maybe
when you
switch on the eq look at the sound
quality improvement we went all the way
up to six
from down to uh three scores so
massive improvement in this algorithm
and similar improvement in in both of
these other schemes although the first
scheme was
superior so this clearly proved this is
a controlled
double-blind testing and just played by
the book in a room that's designed to be
repeatable
and verifiable papers have been written
peer-reviewed and you know read by
millions of people
and that 100 percent was the outcome so
this confirms again a study that was
done years and years back some 20 years
before
and exact same conclusion now
people say well maybe harman does this
because
they don't they can't do a multi-channel
listening test and therefore
they decided to do a you know mono is
cheaper and easier to do
that's what they're doing they're being
lazy well that's not the case because if
you go read
other publications from harmon you see
that they're very proud of this room
that they built
called the harmon multi-channel
listener room mll
and what that is is that it's a room
where you can set up a full surround
system of
two different sets of speakers and it
will shuffle all of them simultaneously
so you can listen to one set of speakers
in multi-channel and then by pressing a
button a few seconds later using these
hydraulic lifts
all these speakers go back and forth and
a new set is presented to you
and you can see a better shot of it over
here
where you know the speakers are sitting
here and and they're all shuffled or not
so harman has this room
but they don't use it hardly anymore or
if they use it they only use it for mono
testing because it just
the results aren't there and so i've
gone to harmon twice
and both times i've taken the double
blind test of speakers
and this is one time picture that i took
when i was there
and it's a much smaller room so much
cheaper to build and it only shuffles
one speaker at a time so this speaker
right now is martin logan that's
in the front there's bmw over there and
there's a jbl
and they shuffle in and out randomly and
a random piece of music plays and you
have a scoring sheet where you give
score and i'll tell you when you're
sitting there
the job is difficult as it is when
you're evaluating speakers it's not an
easy job because
still takes three or four seconds for
speakers to change and then tonality
completely changes
and you've got to judge and you've got
to score these speakers so
everything we can do to simplify the job
we need to do
we don't want to make the job so
difficult for a subjective evaluator
listener
when they're giving us you know mishmash
we should watch the answers we want to
make it simple
as we can and nothing does that more
than that i tell you when i was sitting
there listening blind i had no idea what
was behind there they'd never even told
us what the speakers were
and you'd hear the speakers like this
martin logan had a
massively different sound signature than
all the others
and uh you know in that regard the job
was
simpler so what is it net out to
look this is not a new idea if you if
you haven't heard about it
shame on you not on me or the
researchers this goes
back you know 40 years 38 years dr floyd
tool has been
talking about this in forums and
articles and interviews in his book
that's been out almost eight to ten
years it's just there's no excuse to not
know about it now admittedly
you all consume content from the same
usual sources of
you know typical you know reviewers what
have you and
or your buddies that aren't exposed to
the proper science never seen these
papers
and everything your gut will say hey
look you know you got to do this testing
in
in uh in stereo or multi-channel and so
i can't blame you fully but from here on
i will blame you
because this research is ironclad it's
solid
i've done this testing i've done mono
versus stereo and i'm telling you
mono is just the way to tell you can
hear the tonality you can hear
what is wrong with the speaker why is
this
the fact that you know stereo is not as
good um i have a theory which is what i
call beauty of of of stereo
multi-channel
um stereo obviously sounds a lot
nicer than the mono speaker does a
multi-channel even more
sounds are coming all the way around you
i think the moment we we do that there
um the brain it just gets so much
enjoyment out of that spatial quality
that it gets
lost and can't focus on what's happening
number one number two
there's masking that's happening so if
you have a frequency response error in
one speaker
but the second one is playing the other
channel it can ride on top of this one
and you can't tell the difference
between you know two speakers is
accurately because you're listening to a
mix of speakers
and it homogenizes things there are
different locations in the room
so you don't want to do that i i used to
lead
engineering for broadcast video
companies and would sell to the major
networks and
and uh post production studios and
others and
uh if you look at the professional
monitor they always have a button that
goes to black and white instead of color
and you we
brought our you know effect systems and
others installed
the major network let's say espn or cnn
or
what have your bbc and the first thing
they would do put the picture in black
and white
and look for artifacts because in color
same effect happens the color
fools your eye is pretty is nice
but the resolution and the acuity of the
eye
is higher in black and white so they
would instantly turn off the color with
a button on a broadcast monitor
and then they would find artifacts and
issues they're like oh what's this ring
in the air why is
you know what is timing wrong in here
same thing here
we go to mono because we want to turn
off the beauty of stereo
stereo is an effect produced in
production of music
the two speakers have no communication
with each other it's not like they
play differently because the other one
was turned on also
and we don't want that we want to know
is the speaker properly engineered
does it produce the right fidelity and
then
yes when you use it you listen to two if
you want
i've had at least one person online on
audio science review
that actually did this one from stereo
and he had multiple speakers he was
evaluating
and he switched to mono and came
reported right back he says wow
it was a lot easier and
it's amazing that you know i'm one of
the few people who still does this
it's like hardly anybody outside of
harmon seems to be doing this
you know mono testing it just amazes me
uh i go to shows and everybody's sitting
there pontificating what the sound is
whether sound is good or bad listen to
two channels
yeah of course it's hard so you're gonna
sit there and pontificate
whether you know the system sounds good
or not switch to mono
it's easier it's cheaper it's more
convenient in my case
i only get one speaker to ship back and
forth to me there's a lot of expense and
a hassle involved in shipping two
speakers
back and forth for testing by shipping
one speaker we save half the cost half
to storage
have the main handling and set up and
everything
so of course every other reviewer out
there is doing stereo testing and he
keeps talking about imaging and
everything which is function of the
content
and by the way also functional frequency
response and
they're just lost in the woods that's
why they keep talking about this
nebulous stuff that just does not matter
you know we want to know if the speaker
is high fidelity or it's not high
fidelity
they need to switch to mono you can't
keep putting your head in the sand
saying
oh you know i've got two ears therefore
i gotta listen to two speakers now if
you want you can do a secondary test in
stereo
nobody's stopping you but start with
mono
properly evaluate the sound of a speaker
then go if you want to
listen to two channels good luck because
by the way those two channels
they're room specific what imaging they
create so half the time they're probably
talking about
the you know what's happening in their
room versus what's happening
you know with speaker alone and that's
what we want to do um
one key thing to remember is that you
know when we use measurements they're
100 accurate
because there are measurements right i
don't mean in
in that they answer something but the
objective the machine
measures something you can measure and
measure and measure and we can just
touch and feel that measurement and sell
it
when we use human subjects they're so
variable we want to turn them into
instruments really that's what our use
is we want to turn them into soldiers of
that just we could just stick in front
of speakers say spit out one to
ten numbers say how good the speaker is
and we're gonna help that
human listener become more reliable
training makes it more reliable
knowledge makes them more reliable and
mono listening for speaker
makes that listener more reliable
they're now able to tell differences
even if they're not professionally
trained
they have a better shot of hearing what
the speaker does
and as i've explained even though it's
non-intuitive you absolutely have
imaging with a single speaker when you
have one speaker
reflects of the wall it creates a mirror
image on the other side and the speaker
actually
uh us use the word smear but it's
smearing a good way
that this image shifts it literally
called uh
image shift of a speaker and becomes a
wider thing that's why for center
speakers you want to have white
dispersion because then you can hit the
side walls
and stretch that center speaker to be
the width of your tv or projection
screen
you don't want that sound to come out of
one little point in the middle of the
screen
because the action is on the entire uh
uh display itself but that's for the
topic
um but just know that these things are
important you know the tonality of a
single speaker is important
and the things that we cover there's a
reason i do what i do
don't go around you know especially a
lot of them are just reading some
tonight somebody was calling me a hack
because he said that he just
tested mono there we go i've rested my
case
well no you're a hack if you haven't
spent five seconds
asking you know somebody that knows hey
why is uh you know why mono testing is
better clearly i'm not a
stupid idiot that woke up in the morning
and said i'm just gonna start listening
in mud and when the world thinks it
should be in stereo
there's a reason for it and it happens
to be fortuitous
that we can do this testing in mono it
actually works better
and uh you know it's it's been proven
there's just no doubt about this
and and uh no speaker goes from
bad in mono to great and stereo it just
hasn't happened
you know the rankings that existed mono
also
exists in stereo we're just as listeners
or we're less picky
on this thing and by the way that's why
a lot of you aren't disgusted with
speakers
you own that i measure and i say they're
no good because you're listening to them
in stereo you're much less critical in
stereo
and if you listen to a multi-channel
that's why bose made a living selling
these little acoustic
tiny little crappy speakers because it
was multi-channel and that multi-channel
effect is
just so captivating you know those 5.1
speaker setups that are usually
you know bottom of the line designs and
cost
but you set them up in a multi-channel
system they sound nice because the
content
steals the show and convinces you to
sound good
but you know if you want to know what's
a good speaker you want to start with
the
you know proper analysis and if you
can't do it i'm doing it for you
just don't go around saying you know the
guy's an idiot doing uh
mono testing i stand on the shoulders of
pretty tall people
in doing what i do okay hopefully you uh
could follow this again these papers are
available i'll create a thread on audio
science review
uh website if you want to come and
discuss these things i can code more
from the papers and and
you know prove this point for you but
this should be enough please don't
question it
you're questioning the abcs of proper
controlled listening tests for speakers
how you're supposed to do that okay see
you in a future video bye-bye